one dash cam video getting a whole lot
of attention on social media henderson
mom showing the need for crossing guards
as she has a really close call with one
student on a bike 8 news now reporter
sally jaramillo spoke to parents about
that situation
parents i spoke with say when kids get
out of school this intersection near
lake mead parkway and grand cadence
drive is filled with cars and kids this
raising concerns among many parents say
something needs to be done before it's
too late a video posted on the next door
app has parents expressing concerns as
the mother approaches the busy
intersection a child on a bike veers in
front of her forcing her to use her
breaks
it's scary
very scary it's tough because
i post a picture of my son my son was
hit by a car going to school on his on
his bike alicia shannon is familiar with
the devastation that can happen to a
family in a matter of minutes lake mead
parkway here
grand cadence it's
it's fine now because it's the middle of
the day but in the mornings it's very
very busy and it can be dangerous for
the kids denise spencer came across the
video and says there should be
supervision
some kids parents are already off to
work and the kids have to come out here
and get to school for themselves
and no there's no crossing guards have a
human person
keeping watch over the kids as they
cross
i think it's it's so helpful
it would have something like that would
have stopped my son that day spencer
says as parents we can educate our kids
but more change is needed just like kids
and clark county schools needs
protection kids in charter school also
need protected now the school near this
intersection is pine crest cadence
academy and it's a charter school and it
does not provide crossing guards the
same way ccsd does reporting sally
jaramillo live local now